is wrong shall be established it seems
as if Islam conquered him
assalamualaikum guys welcome to Ali
dawa's channel before we start the video
this video is sponsored by Islamic Quran
manuals let me see yes no I need this
I'm taking it from my family that's what
I'm saying it's a high demand I mean you
have to keep saying is there anymore so
those are the premium ones yeah the best
colorful comprehensive and subhanallah
if you've got problem with your
vocabulary we have the on the left
hand side to help you and this is true
come on these are the paperback versions
I prefer this version mother this is me
because you open it you've got the viral
bound you just have it on the desk the
way it is subhanallah you guys can see
you've got Arabic it's colorful I've
helped design it so guys the links are
going to be in the description learning
the Quran in a fun accessible way salaam
alaikum guys so welcome to this video
let's get straight to the point so we
had a Christian or maybe maybe a Hebrew
Israelite who snuck in I mean that's the
correct yes grammatically yes because I
would say sneaked in but my English
vocabulary is increasing so you've
probably seen sneaked in because Nico
accepted Islam that's right and you know
what maybe this guy's gonna cry because
he found that out found that out yeah
okay so basically this guy's name I
don't know his name so he is this is
this post and this is what he said only
one nation under God Israel okay they
kept telling me I wouldn't be able to go
because I'm not Muslim but I went and
conquered and Christ is King so this is
what he had to say and there's something
let's see how we conquered the Kaaba
yeah I'm trying to here we go this is
him he
but the thing is this it's actually
quite ironic and quite funny yeah so
here's the sum of the videos and there's
him walking let's see look let's watch
this one so he's
very special day today
I'm going to Mecca
I am a god
see he said I am a God I'm the Prince of
the king I think he's quoting scripture
is wrong shall be established
what's up
I think that's that's it I don't think
the scripture says what's up oh that's
interesting I left the comment and it's
gone oh it's gone quite interesting yeah
no one cares Ali let's go on with the
video yeah okay this is very interesting
okay because he's saying that he
conquered yeah now to me it's very
interesting yeah okay it seems as if
Islam conquered him because if you think
about it bro look what did he have to do
to enter those lands he would have to
number one show that he's a Muslim it
has to be verbally or via a some sort of
a certificate maybe that was fake maybe
he had to go to a Muslim claim I'm a
Muslim I'm taking shahada and they have
to give him a certificate wow so he had
to go down that route then he had to
enter those lands and get into his
Muslim then he most likely maybe the guy
even the pilgrimage maybe don't tell off
even though it's not valid yet okay so
the point is what that you wanted to
mock Islam or conquer whatever it may be
but in reality you yourself got
conquered by your own tongue and by is
it and I just found that really profound
and he's like yeah Jesus is King all
this kind of stuff so to me it's like
why would someone imagine us as Muslims
would we go down that route you never
see as Muslims doing this like
desecrating the holy scriptures
insulting their religion our religion
tells us not to do that to see
Christians who propagate this loving and
you know attitude and for him to go to
those secret lands and do that I mean
imagine us stooping to that level where
we're going to the Vatican or somewhere
where it's just for the Christians I
mean we don't do such stuff why do you
think Christians Resort such stuff I I
don't think Christians resort to that
stuff yeah but unfortunately you know
what is because Islam is the fastest
growing religion in the world it's at
the Forefront of a lot of efforts like
against LGBT and we're very vocal where
the way our teachings are we're involved
there's regular worship like we've got
Ramadan
you got Hajj you've got all sorts so
even when I hear certain Christians talk
this is an issue for them they're like
oh they they seem so dedicated to their
faith so what do you do either you beat
him or you join them and here obviously
they can't beat us so this guy is
clearly joining us so all he is showing
he's exemplifying Hajj like he's making
a video and yo what's up like someone's
greeting him yeah someone's greeting him
um with the greetings of Peace yes with
the same greetings that Jesus used the
same greetings of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon
um them both used uh and then he's
wearing the Gob again and he's showing
the Kaaba which is hundreds of thousands
of people that come ambulating the Kaaba
a circular motion that has only one
Center non-stop non-stop in fact you go
there two o'clock at midnight you go
there whatever time you've got people
circumambulating it to exemplify to
proclaim the Oneness of God people
dressed all in white all equal doesn't
matter you can't tell who's the king
who's the paupo who's this who's that
subhanallah and he's there and
this is an own gold frankly it is and
that's exactly what I saw bro it's like
like this Allah says in the Quran they
plan and we panel where the best the
plan is he went there to somehow you
know maybe humility or just mock the
religion yeah I couldn't get in you went
in and got conquered literally you went
in and got conquered and you made a post
and it just there was people in the
comments even Christians are like you
know why did you find the need to do
that you know I mean it would would any
Muslim a True Believer Muslim if they
gave us if they gave me a million pounds
ability if they give the entire group
and said say I'm a Christian once I say
to hell with you I would never ever say
I'm a Christian and I don't find the
need to go to the Vatican and disrespect
them so it shows again and they say like
in my country they say what did they say
in your country the hand that you can't
bend kiss it hmm so that's exactly what
he did he couldn't bend it so he ended
up kissing it he conquered it
approach actually for elders you do that
did you know that like for when elderly
comes in you have to do this so in my
culture the arm that you cannot bear I'm
two months older than you so it makes
sense exactly why do you think you're
trying to put it because
like an uncle like a Granddad like a old
person like you know the bones are like
you know crumbling and like a little
weasel on it
too quickly there yeah are you excited
because we imagine you're a big man now
yeah you know I've noticed I've noticed
your weights dumbbell weights have gone
up so no it's the same I want to say I'm
proud of you no no no that's actually
very impressive but coming to topic
brother and sisters I think that's all
we wanted to say now don't go and send
Hate to this person yeah you know I left
a nice comment alhamdulillah and I think
that does the job and a few other
Muslims did leave it because at the end
of the day Islam is growing and these
people are hurt and they are burning and
their rage is bringing them to the holy
lands and we may be inshallah we ask
Allah to guide them that he comes back
as a Believer rather than a disbeliever
inshallah and I'll say that look if
Islam wasn't a threat if Islam wasn't
glorious if it wasn't so Majestic he
wouldn't feel the need to go out of his
way to go there and I pray for his
guidance in my guidance of his followers
and in you guys I do that and of course
Ali as well I do that as well but I was
actually at one moment of time I was
thinking to myself if I saw that
Instagram post and I was in the Caba and
I saw him
well I I genuinely pictured in my mind
literally smashing his head bro like
like
envisioned like well I envisioned like
if I I would if I saw that post I would
be going and looking for him and I'll
say this very openly I I think I would
have ripped him apart bro because
because no no you know why bro it's just
it's just the disrespect that you're
trying to do even though you got
conquered like a little weasel you're
like a little boy but bro well I would
have just loved to do that like where he
thinks he's got away with it and he has
one right hook coming from nowhere for
you and he wakes her mind yeah and he
wakes up and he wakes up in America I
don't change your mind I wish uh but
anyways
no it's good just so he knows we're not
here like you know we're just apologetic
yeah this time is very you know to the
point so that you would have seen that
side to us as well uh if we was happy to
be there well anyway probably would have
told a guard there no I would not turn
the guard there but God would have yeah
of the area but actually no if we follow
the law of the land I think anyway
something else would have happened to
him yeah anyways uh Ali's just gassed
because his marriage documentaries out
he wouldn't you wouldn't be doing that
it's just getting excited he's got a
million subscribers and I would do this
to the person all right Ellie okay there
buddy thank you thanks for the legally
saving me there but anyways that's it
inshallah may Allah bless you guys and
take care and don't forget to buy your
Hawaii yes the manuals to learn the
Quran regardless of what age you are in
a very colorful concise exciting fun way
you have to get a copy of this keep it
concise
[Music]